ronnie is of course moving to vegas very
soon i don't know the exact date
you know what he's sitting in
practically an empty room now with just
boxes and you and stephanie have been
arguing about packing because uh
this is the real rumor i heard what
ronnie's out of his [ __ ] mind because
it turns out stephanie's got
no pictures of boyfriends that she dated
before ronnie
and she ain't throwing him high school
you know yeah and ronnie's all jealous
she wants her to throw him out she says
she has these photo albums i said well
what's in them
and she goes um you know pictures of old
boyfriends and family and stuff like
that i go
whoa pictures of who and
she goes old boyfriends i said like from
when she goes to
high school and her prom and all this
kind of [ __ ]
you got any pictures of old girlfriends
well here's what happened
before i got married i was engaged to
some other chick
and i had a picture of me it was like an
eight by ten like i think
my parents took it and had it blown up
and [ __ ]
and it was in my parents house and i
when i was
going through [ __ ] i found this picture
i showed it to her because i wanted to
show how different i looked then and
everything and then after i showed it to
her
i ripped it up right in front of her and
threw in the garbage
good for you and she goes why'd you do
that don't you want to save that
and that's how i found out about
here's ronnie being interviewed about uh
the situation with stephanie and
her ex-hillbilly boyfriend what kind of
things is she having trouble throwing up
like albums from old boy with old
boyfriends and [ __ ]
and she goes what do you care it's it's
it's just pictures and it's from
when i was you know younger i'm sure
she's probably got [ __ ] cards from
them too you know like
birthday cards or valentine's day cards
i think it's just
stupid i haven't seen this stuff but i
don't want to see it i didn't manage to
see it so
maybe she's keeping you know when i
[ __ ] drop dead or something she could
always call him or something i don't
know
so is she going to get to pack all that
stuff up yeah
yeah i let her pack it because i talked
to my shrink about he goes what are you
worried about
well thank god you got to shrink i'm the
[ __ ] down
her old boyfriend still lives in [ __ ]
he works
or some [ __ ] yeah he made it big in the
world he was he was a
in a band or some [ __ ] they thought they
were going to be like the [ __ ]
beatles i guess or something
that that went real far old [ __ ]
hillbilly boyfriend [ __ ] [ __ ]
then he started complaining that
stephanie's become too independent
what if you threw out all of stephanie's
picture albums and stuff would she get
pissed do you think
oh yeah i'd probably wind up throwing
her out of the [ __ ] house
really yeah because we'd wind up [ __ ]
probably breaking up
she's very independent man she's a very
into became
even more and more independent as she
got older too independent for you
lately yeah what are independent
thoughts just her in general with her
[ __ ]
thinking and everything how dare you
think
yeah no i just say stop you know what
ronnie good for you with the shrink
i need to know are you still working
with um the hypnotist
yes and can he help you with these these
feelings about her independence yeah
yeah it calms me down
okay like king kong they have to like
inject them with a tranquilizer dart